it's harvest time again three times a
year farmer Khoya acutally cuts the ripe
cocoa pods from his trees plantations
were set up in Togo more than a hundred
years ago by the then colonial power
Germany to this day
cocoa remains one of Togo's major
exports most of our coolies crop still
ends up in European factories where it's
processed into chocolate and we'd like
to eat it ourselves but we don't very
often we just can't afford it but
everyone loves to eat chocolate here
especially cocoa is one of the 25
poorest countries in the world
two-thirds of the population works in
agriculture
besides cocoa cocoa exports cotton and
coffee until now almost all of togo's
Kokua has been exported without being
processed in the country most to release
only no chocolate as a foreign product
but a small enterprise in the capital
ami wants to change this and has started
to produce a chocolate made in Togo the
chocolate plant still only consists of a
couple of rented rooms in a loam a
suburb 15 workers mostly women heat the
cocoa mass and mix in sugar and spices
this year they've already produced 2
tonnes around 100 bars a day the head of
the co-operative comia Goku helps with
the packaging he studied psychology in
Germany before returning home he got the
idea of starting up togo's first
chocolate factory 3 years ago when he
was working on a project with togolese
students a book who is convinced that
precisely because the operation is so
small his chocolate brand choco Togo can
compete with the big manufacturers the
true everything inside not good brings
everything and sometimes tuned
everything are true in the in the in the
fire in the machine in choco taco
before we roast our choco chocolate we
select every ground and about the size
also those who are not good are removed
completely because we are the first what
eating our chocolate Kamiya Bocuse
business now supplies supermarkets
throughout Togo a bar of choco choco
costs one euro eighty but his bars have
a distinct advantage the high cocoa
content of nearly 100% means they don't
melt in the tropical heat you can see
our chocolate these chocolates now the
temperature will be petty a bit is so
very hot in the next six months
Komi add beaucoup plans to sell his
heat-resistant chocolate in Europe as
well he's already found an agent there
and he still recalls those summers in
Germany when his friends used to
complain about melting chocolate